when you're reading screenplays from
unknown writers how far into the
screenplay do you know
whether it's good or bad yeah well i
think problems can
show up very early in a script right um
but they don't always so so
some scripts have a great setup they
have a great first act and they
you know sort of have the right pace
right away they get the story rolling
and we feel like things are happening
we're invested
and then in act two things
fall apart basically like if their
protagonist stops pursuing the goal
we don't really know what's going on so
um
i mean i guess the answer is if if a
script has
global problems that sort of cover the
entire script then you'll
probably know within the first five
pages or so
um definitely i think if it has
if it has like major structural problems
with
all the structure overall structure as a
whole i would say
by by you know page 15 or so you know
that there's a problem because you're
waiting for something to happen
and one of the most common problems is
that nothing's happening
right like it's just not getting going
so um so i would say that you can know
right away you can know pretty quickly
that a script has some issues
or needs some work um but i would also
say you can't always tell
what a script or often you can't tell
what a script's issues are
until later until you've seen sort of
what they're trying to accomplish
or gotten a true sense of like what the
story really is or what they're going
for and a lot of times you don't have
that
sense of what they're going for until
later in the script until
towards the end of act 2 at least you
know so that
that probably sheds light on the need
for
really having your script in good shape
before you submit it and it's not
it's not your personal thing it's more
of an industry standard that
if something within the first few pages
isn't good it's just going to be
rejected
for time's sake yeah i will say so
usually when i'm reading a script i'm
reading it
to help right i'm reading it to try to
figure out what isn't working and see
where i can
um provide that insight to the writer so
that they can make it better
a lot of people in the industry as you
know are not reading for that purpose
they're
they're looking for projects that they
want to get involved in and so
since you are submitting your script
sort of asking someone to get involved
in your project
um hopefully what you've submitted will
get them excited and interested right
away so you
want to be able to get them interested
on page one
get them sort of hooked in the story by
that inciting incident
um you know build and escalate your
story
uh sort of throughout the rest as
they're as the characters pursuing that
goal so that their
your reader is invested and emotionally
engaged and all that stuff through the
whole thing and then you want to deliver
like some emotionally satisfying
resolution and hopefully some genuine
emotion by the end of the story as well
so that they come the reader comes away
from your script
moved and or entertained in some way you
know so that they want to
get involved and help you make it if we
look back at let's say the recording
industry they would say well put the
best three songs
up front first because some a r person
or what i don't know i
don't really know too much about the
music industry but i just remember
hearing that that
they're gonna be listening to those
three and if by maybe one or two in it's
not good
it goes it goes in in a bad pile so yeah
although i
you know i mean the other the sort of
flip side of
doing that i guess there's a lot of
emphasis placed on making sure that your
first 10 pages is so good and really
hooky
and grabs your reader which is great of
course you want it to do that
but i have read scripts where it was
very clear that the first 10 pages were
were really worked on and then after
that there there were clear
issues that still hadn't been addressed
and um you know so you don't want that
either you want
you want a great strong start that hooks
your reader but then you want to
deliver on what you've promised them you
want them to become
emotionally invested and to stay engaged
all the way through
and to really care about the outcome and
and to feel something at the end you
know
interesting okay so so then you can't
really cheat it where you're like i'm
going to make these 10 pages the top
three songs of the album
and then it turns out that the rest of
it is just all b-side stuff that no one
wants to listen to yeah
and and that's gonna that's gonna bite
you in the end yeah i don't think you
can do that because the purpose of
making your first 10 pages really really
strong
is to get someone to read the rest of it
right so
the rest of it has to be worth reading
too
you